alors mason de la présidente moldave a
dit que l'estimé que ces explosions
étaient dues à des luttes luttes de
pouvoir à l'intérieur de la transnistrie
cette république séparatiste qui en
réalité est occupé et contrôlé par la
russie depuis
1992 elle a dit que c'était l'hypothèse
qu'ils étudiaient pour le moment mais
que les informations continuer à se
recueillir elle a dit que la moldavie
renforcerait le dispositif sécuritaire
autour de la transe district la moldavie
bien sûr rester ouverte au dialogue pour
essayer de trouver une solution à ce
conflit qui dure maintenant depuis le
début des années 90 et elle a aussi
confirmé qu'il y avait eu si vous voulez
un quatrième explosion il y a eu cette
attaque à la grenade sur un bâtiment
gouvernemental dans la capitale de la
transnistrie tiraspol hier et ce matin
deux tours de radio qui ont été détruits
des tours de radio qui imitaient les
stations russe et puis mahias on doit
confirmer qu'il y ait aussi une
explosion sur l'aérodrome de tiraspol la
capitale de la transnistrie